let me ask you about lazy susan cuz i
love this this is you playing a woman
yeah so i hmm
when I was 21 years old I was living in
Chicago I grew up in Chicago and I got a
call from my agent saying um you have an
audition tomorrow to replace the white
guy on in living color and I was like
wait Jim Carrey is leaving the show and
she said yeah and so I went with my bag
of like wigs and accents and characters
and all these things that I've worked on
and and one of the characters was this
this this girl this woman Susan and and
I'm still waiting to hear if I got part
but then we cut to like decades later a
friend of mine it was like you know what
you should do something with that
character was so funny and you should
call lazy susan and I was like oh I love
that title and I'm like a light bulb
went off and I thought what a wonderful
kind of built in somatic reason to talk
you know to portray a person who's
spinning out of control like a lazy
susan who can't figure out their life
and so and then I'm top of it I was like
I've never seen I thought it might be
out there but I've ever seen a film
where a man plays a woman without any
like other kind of underlying pretext
you know to do the thing where the
comedy comes from the character not the
fact that a man is playing a woman we
have a still but you are you are quite
convincing do you like yourself as Susan
do you like yourself as a woman I like I
personally for me I do not enjoy
dressing up as a woman
not to judge those who do things are
really rough over there with you and
Liza oh they're actually better than
ever
I'm I'm getting to be their real me at
long last we have a clip here from lazy
susan I don't even know if you know
about about this clip you may know I
think I may are we am I going to watch
you play put it in
after we put it in afterwards yeah in
fact we're gonna replace you with
another actor you're gonna be played by
Richard kind okay again again closing
get me oh yes me I got you
here's some headbands awesome
that's some crazy glue oh yeah I go
crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
there is no fill people don't call me
people I told you I hate that at the
word out lazy susan is gonna be
available on video and demand everywhere
April third there is no better time
right now than for good streaming
content I mean this is actually you know
it's I'm watching a ton of great stuff
just because that's what you do now we
are yeah we are all home and so I'm
grateful to people like you that have
made good new stuff that I can watch
well thank you my dear yeah I'm really
excited about it really proud about it
and and I'll be watching all your movies
okay that's Bob there look I never tried
I tried for a while to make it in the
film but it just didn't pop for me
that's all well I'm sorry you didn't
succeed incredibly at doing I've never
been in a movie and I've always thought
I would look horrible on a movie screen
well I got a little I've aim that would
be 60 feet tall little squirly thin lips
well you got you well the good news is
nobody goes to the theater anymore so I
had to wait for movies to die that I
could drive into so your 60-foot vein
now
this is the right medium for me it's
taken me 30 years but I finally figured
it out
Thank You Sean thank you so much please
give my best to Scottie tell him to stop
jumping up and down on top of you and
really thank you so much for being here
everyone check out lazy susan and I will
see you soon in better times okay men
thank you I bow to you thank you